what's with the jeans by the way why are
you wearing mine but do not let shirt
right now uh what you're wearing my
sweatshirt I don't know it fits me
perfectly like a glove I think it looks
better on me let me tell you I wore that
on the flight to Salt Lake City and then
yeah back from Salt Lake City let's get
a look at what I'm wearing it is a real
talking point so wait wait first of all
I just want you to see what you look
like
yeah when you wear this it's just one
good look at what you've been wearing
that's why I put it on today so you can
feel the experience that I've been yeah
having you know I feel there's so many
different things that happen with that
sweatshirt ah first of all horse
so Doug Mallard and I went to Salt Lake
City and he was like wow and then I told
him how you said your your take was that
I look like the retarded guy that goes
to the library every day that and like
it's like you teach specialists yeah so
when I was on the plane first of all
people would board so great and I could
I would see them go like yeah of course
crazy you know people look one of the
flight attendants came over and talked
to me like I was super special and I
realized that I almost sounded special
back because I was actually putting
together i-i've almost confused why I
got it you know I mean so I was trying
to tell her she goes she was working
walking through the cart with the aisle
with the cart and she goes
so are those jellyfish on your
sweatshirt yeah I've never seen that
before
what where'd you get that oh I had it
made and she goes why did you do that
yeah and then I was confused I didn't
realize I didn't remember that it's
actually it was made first and then I go
I want to get it in my mind I was
thinking of like my my first special
where I have a joke where I can't you
can't do a jellyfish last week
48-bit mm-hmm so I go I I didn't want to
explain that I do comedy so I just said
I talked about it so then I got one and
I was like oh no I actually sound
retarded because I'm going I talk about
it and then I wanted it and she goes
that's really nice and she talked to me
like I was really really special yeah
and then she goes I go I have another
one one with a raven on it and then I
pulled it up I'm like my phone was out
and she goes I'm listening she was
serving other people drinks oh my god
and then I was like paging through my
camera roll I was like this one is me
what a raven on my sweatshirt
why did you you you show did you show
her the other one - no I didn't show her
the hannibal one yeah
I showed her the Raven right okay I tell
you why I like you wearing the jellyfish
and the rave yeah go ahead
because I know you're not cheating on me
because there's no woman in the world
that's gonna lay you wearing the
jellyfish why why do you say that so
return
it's so embarrassing do you see that you
don't see it you don't have any sexual
feelings zero point negative yeah so bad
really babe this is craziness
it's not crazy it looks really crazy
wait you don't think any woman would be
like whoa what's up with him I think a
normal woman be like yeah like that
Stewart has had that reaction like how
she talked to me I actually thought this
later the guy's the flight was
progressing it felt like somebody went I
dare you to ask the guy out that
retarded guy about his of course and
then of course and and and then she won
like 20 bucks for talking to me like oh
my god he just said he talked about them
she felt good about herself that day
like you know when like confident right
she was like I I did a good deed by
talking to that real nice retarded boy
that's for you an economy yeah yeah see
she's like I'm a good person I talked to
retarded people like they're one of us
would have it that's what she was doing
fuck man I wish I was in first because
then they would have been made
Wow doesn't make a wish yeah but they
would have just thought that you were
like an eccentric millionaire if you're
in first class now you're just the
eccentric guy with the jellyfish
somebody posted when I cuz I posted a
picture of me in that sweatshirt yeah
they said this is how I imagined like
the the seat like the guy that the
startup CEO right who runs some tech
company dresses like some guys money
who's like fuck it yeah for sure and I
laughed so hard cuz I could I could see
that the guy the guy was like I have a
billion dollars I'm just gonna wear a
jelly right this is either retarded or
fuck you money right right of which I'm
neither I'm not retarded I don't have
fuck you and fuck getting pussy yeah
Thanks so I'm super stoked about that
is this a concern of yours what you
worry about that not really no not
really
oh my god it's a fuck you - that fuck
you